Modern smartphones
have to strike
an on balance between
performance, thermal output,
and battery consumption.
And normally when a user's
purchasing a device,
these are the last
things on their minds
My name is Colt McAnlis.
And unbeknownst to game devs,
these physical properties
of a phone can manifest into
some really weird performance
issues.
You see all modern
mobile CPUs have
a process known as
"frequency scaling."
That is, in order
to conserve battery,
the hardware will reduce the
amount of voltage supplied
to the CPU, depending
on a variety of factors.
This dip in supplied
energy helps
reduce battery consumption
as well as thermal output
but has the downside of slowing
down your CPU in the process.
Now there's a variety of factors
that can cause this behavior,
but there's two of them
that you need to know about.
The first type of
frequency throttling
has to do with the load
capacity of the CPU.
If your CPU is
chugging along and then
suddenly hits a consistent
run of low compute frames,
the CPU governor--
which is the thing that
controls the frequency--
can reduce the frequency
supplied to the CPU, reducing
its computational power
and thus saving energy.
Subsequent frames,
of course, will
run a bit slower since
there's less power being given
to the CPU, which means you'll
see your frame time go up.
This creates a problem, however,
once your CPU load returns back
to normal.
Since the frequency
has been downscaled,
you could end up with
large performance spikes
since your CPU has
been running slower.
This performance hit will
continue until the CPU governor
decides to upscale your
frequency back at which case
you should be back in
your original state.
The good news is that
this type of throttling
is entirely under
your control, and you
can address it before
things go badly.
By timing your CPU
frame, you can easily
detect when consistent
lulls in CPU load occur;
and for the next few
frames, add some work
to ensure that the CPU
is getting artificially
pegged at the right frame rate.
This will keep your
CPU from scaling
and reduce your spikes
in your frame time.
By the way, things
like spin loops
are particularly nice solutions
that help chew up frame time.
Or you can do
something more awesome,
like path finding for
200 zombie entities.
But that's really
another episode.
Thankfully your Android
device reports the amount
of frequency scaling that's
occurring on your device.
So you can determine if
this is actually a problem.
To get access to
this information
simply read a few files from
an oddly cryptic system path,
and you can determine if you're
getting artificially scaled
or not.
Now the second
type of throttling
is a little bit more
difficult to deal
with since it has
everything to do
with the thermal properties
of the client device.
See one of the dominant
trends in mobile computing
has to do with
heat distribution.
Typically on desktop
CPUs, they have
this obnoxiously large heat sink
fan attached to it specifically
to get rid of heat and keep
your computer from melting.
Now in contrast,
mobile devices don't
have the amount of physical
room for such a powerful heat
sink and have to find different
ways to distribute heat.
And more so, each
manufacturer likes
taking into account
different thermal properties
and use cases for their designs.
For example, some
Android devices
are built to handle
long-term gaming.
While others expect more
moderate levels of usage
and may not provide enough
airflow or sink space to get
rid of heat effectively.
As such, once the thermal
letoff becomes a problem,
the CPU will become throttled to
help reduce the amount of heat
being generated by the hardware.
The end game here
is that eventually,
due to form factor
or running duration,
your CPU can get overheated
and then throttled and remain
that way until the heat
properties of the device return
back to normal operating values.
And once in this state, your CPU
frame time is going to suffer.
Now generally,
there's no good way
to be reactive about this type
of throttling as it has much
less to do with
your code and more
to do with the thermal
properties of the device--
unless you're doing
something really crazy,
like trying to do protein
folding on someone's handheld.
In which case, shame on you.
Proactive developers
will collect performance
characteristics
about the devices
that their game
is run on and can
reduce computational
complexity, features,
or quality for those devices.
But even then, that's
a lot work to do
to avoid this thermal problem.
Of course the first
step in fighting
any type of thermal
throttling is aggressively
optimizing the
performance of your game
to ensure that you're not
wasting battery, frame
time, or thermal letoff
on your consumer's device.
So as always, keep calm.
Profile your code.
And remember, perf matters.